deux invités à présent dans le 7 8 pour
revenir sur cette opération chacun ses
racines et l'Europe pour tous une
opération qui consiste pour tous les
citoyens d'Île-de-France d'Angleterre de
Turquie et d'Allemagne a travaillé sur
la mémoire familiale lors d'ateliers
cinématographique bonsoir à Patrick
Bonin vous êtes donc président de la
Maison de l'Europe des Yvelines
vice-président de la Maison de l'Europe
des dans les Yvelines et puis également
sur ce plateau Christine Colleville
bonsoir vous êtes coordinatrice
administrative donc de la Maison de
l'Europe dans les Yvelines le but
affiché de cette opération chacun ses
racines l'Europe pour tous c'est de
trouver son visage dans l'image de
l'autre c'est comme ça que c'est
présenté et c'est à dire tout à fait
donc c'est un projet qui a démarré il y
a à peu près un an et demi j'ai
rencontré un réalisateur intervenant qui
avait pour idée de revenir sur le passé
à partir des archives familiales donc
des films super 8 principalement et des
photographies et de pouvoir renouer avec
son passé en travaillant sur le futur et
en construisant un film de fiction
d'expérimentation
à partir de ce pulse d'image et cette
personne faisait ça en Île-de-France à
un niveau national local et nous avons
proposé à ce réalisateur de le faire à
un niveau européen donc de partager au
sein d'un collectif avec l'Angleterre
l'Allemagne la Turquie et la France des
images de famille qui ont donné lieu à 5
courts métrages un travail collectif sur
la mémoire familiale une transmission
intergénérationnelle on va détailler
justement un petit peu cette opération
durant les prochaines minutes mais juste
tout de même cette question si vous
organisez cette opération ça veut dire
que l'Europe et puis tout ce qu'on peut
aussi mettre derrière l'échange le
partage aujourd'hui ça ne signifie plus
grand chose pour les différents citoyens
des différents pays je dirais que
l'Europe de l'Europe aussi
en Europe en tout cas nous permet grâce
à des dispositifs européens la
Commission européenne en a un certain
nombre de réaliser ce genre de projet et
qui mettent en relation des gens qui
n'auraient pas pu se rencontrer dans un
échange interculturel et créatif et
c'est grâce quand même à la Commission
européenne à des fonds européens mais
aussi à d'autres financeurs que ce type
de projet existe et
très valorisant pour les gens de tout
pays parce que l'Europe c'est ça aussi
c'est uni dans la diversité justement
aussi sur le plan politique ça permet de
concrétiser assez un petit peu l'Europe
de montrer aux citoyens que ça sert à
quelque chose qu'on peut échanger
rencontrer des gens effectivement je
repose cette question par rapport aux
désamour de l'Europe actuellement et à
chaque fois qu'on se voit vous en mettez
ça sur le tapis on s'était vu pour le 9
mai c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui il y a de
grands enjeux on sait qu'on est en crise
mais comme le dit Christine sur c'est un
projet qui permet de fédérer les gens et
de montrer aussi qu'on a des choses en
commun avec la famille la famille c'est
une valeur qui commune pour tout le
monde et même si on est en situation de
crise l'Europe elle a une sorte de gén
créatif et grâce à ces projets aidés ça
permet de mettre tout ça en exergue et
finalement de dépasser un peu ce
pessimisme ambiant vous savez Baudelaire
avait inventé le spleen on peut imaginer
que ce vieux continent qui est l'Europe
et en période de spleen mais on va en
sortir de la création et c'est ce que
fait ce projet et donc pour cette
opération vous avez réuni des gens donc
de toutes les générations lors de ces
différents ateliers qui ont débuté en
août 2011 en tout cas le projet a été
lancé en août 2011 on prenne bien chacun
a partagé ses propres photos ses propres
films déjà au niveau national on a fait
un appel à la population jeune et moins
jeune pour récolter des images de
famille et des vidéos des films anciens
Super 8 et donc effectivement il y a eu
une contribution tout à fait sympathique
de la part de famille pour nous apporter
ces images principalement sur le
territoire des Mureaux puisque c'est la
ville partenaire et nous avons travaillé
avec la Mission Locale intercommunale
des Mureaux et les jeunes et des moins
jeunes qui sont habitants du territoire
francilien ont contribué à ce projet par
leur propre image et ensuite il y a une
séquence d'écriture tout à fait un
atelier de cinéma de recyclage c'était
environ 15 jours de travail aux Mureaux
puis à Londres pour le court métrage
européen environ aussi 15 jours et donc
avec écriture d'un scénario addition de
dialogue création de donc de dialogue
apport de musique de son parce que tous
ces films étaient muets ce sont des
histoires vraies les images que l'on
voit le texte on va avoir un extrait
tout à l'heure ce corresponde
de création long il y a une part de
création puisque ça c'est un projet qui
permet de se transposer vers l'avenir et
de créer un petit peu le parcours
migratoire qu'on souhaiterait avoir vécu
et donc c'est un petit peu dans ce sens
là que le sous-titre du projet est
trouvé son image dans le visage des
autres de l'autre toutes ces générations
on va voir un extrait d'un de ses courts
métrages qui a été réalisé l'autre côté
des choses il est question d'arriver
d'un étranger du côté des Yvelines
justement du côté des Mureaux pour
travailler à l'usine
Varon mars
je viens d'Allemagne d'origine on va
dire je viens d'Allemagne je suis allé à
Paris pour visiter Paris
et puis là j'ai vu que il y avait
croûtes chef qui était dans l'usine
donc je suis venu avec ma caméra j'ai
une question à te poser en fait as-tu
une copine une copine j'en ai plein des
copines à peu près combien
quand on aime un compte pas
ça fait longtemps que tu travaillais ici
bah oui depuis l'inauguration 52 ce soir
tu viens dancing tu m'invites à danser
juste pour boire un coup histoire de
faire un peu plus connaissance
dès le lendemain Marcel m'accueille chez
lui au Mureaux
il me dit
éditeur ce serait peut-être l'occasion
d'utiliser ton bidule pour nous filmer
voilà donc pour cet extrait extrait de
l'un des courts métrages qui a pu être
réalisé l'échange je sais pas c'est
facilement justement entre les
différents participants ils étaient de
35 à peu près vous avez un mini 35
personnes au total par rapport au projet
dans sa globalité mais à l'atelier de
cinéma de recyclage donc des Mureaux on
a rassemblé environ une dizaine de
personnes parce que mener un atelier
avec des amateurs c'est jamais facile et
il a fallu d'abord que les gens
s'expriment librement sur leur propre
vie parce que il fallait illustrer et
expliquer les images et ensuite il y a
eu un travail technique plus technique
sur la réalisation du film donc
l'intervenant réalisateur a bien sûr
encadré ces personnes et à permis à ce
qu'elle comprenne bien le la création
d'un film court-métrage pour le grand
public c'est le grand public veut
découvrir ces différents courts métrages
que vous avez donc réalisés dans le
cadre de ces ateliers c'est possible il
y a eu plusieurs déjà valorisation de
ces 5 films nous sortons d'une rencontre
européenne la semaine dernière où nous
avons pu être accueillis dans le cadre
festival le festival du film de famille
de Saint-Ouen les cinq films ont été
projetés dans ce cadre-là et à partir de
maintenant chacun est libre de pouvoir
valoriser dans le cadre de ses propres
activités tous ces films de famille nous
avons travaillé avec la Arcadie dans le
cadre du dispositif passeur d'image et
en tant que producteur Arcadie
souhaitait également
comment respecter l'intimité des gens et
surtout présenter le projet et ne pas
mettre ce genre de film directement sans
explication sur le net par exemple mais
à partir de maintenant les
co-réalisateurs toutes les délégations
peuvent le faire librement
voilà c'est une belle aventure humaine
et européenne je dirais elle enseigne
énormément de choses sur
l'interculturalité et elle
porte aussi des valeurs de tolérance
d'écoute mutuelle parce qu'il n'est
jamais évident puisque ces quatre
partenaires
pays ne se n'avaient pas l'habitude de
travailler ensemble auparavant la
Turquie la France et l'Angleterre et
donc cinq partenaires structurels si
vous me permettez c'est avec la Mission
Locale intercommunale des Mureaux
partenaires avec les jeunes et donc il
n'est pas facile de que tout le monde se
coordonne et donc ça a été un joli
travail à ce niveau là parce que qui n'a
pas encore abouti complètement puisque
l'année 2013 il y a encore deux
rencontres européennes et puis
donc de tout ce travail un guide des
bonnes pratiques qui sera affaibli en
2013 justement de ce guide qui pourra
donner un
exemple en tout cas européen sur ce
projet donc c'est l'une des missions
l'une des opérations menées donc par
cette Maison de l'Europe j'imagine qu'il
y en a d'autres quels sont les projets
phares du moment les choses qui sont
développées à la Maison de l'Europe pour
justement promouvoir cette Europe et
donner l'envie à chacun à chaque citoyen
de
renouer avec l'Europe vous parliez de
des amours à chaque fois que je vous
fais venir sur ce plateau on parle de
désamour de l'Europe
la Maison de l'Europe c'est une
association qui est ouverte à tous et
qui permet de relier les citoyens à
toute la aux institutions européennes au
fonctionnement et donc d'apporter des
ressources documentaires et d'expliquer
les choses en matière de fonctionnement
européen ensuite pour cela la Maison de
l'Europe des Yvelines mène des actions
elle elle promeut des dispositifs par
exemple volontariat européen on fait des
réunions d'information bimensuelles pour
expliquer aux jeunes comment partir
réaliser une mission de volontariat en
Europe et puis des différents projets
sur la citoyenneté avec les conseils
locaux de jeunes par exemple de 5 pays
là se mettent en étant est en cours
actuellement nous avons un déplacement
la semaine prochaine date du premier au
7 décembre en Italie à propos de ce
projet la citoyenneté chez vous ça
fonctionne comment on va regarder juste
avant de conclure cet entretien un autre
extrait des documentaires qui ont été
réalisés le bonheur rouge cette fois-ci
voilà toujours réalisé à partir de
documents de famille et puis lors de ces
différents ateliers dans le cadre de
cette opération
des racines une Europe c'est le but de
cette opération donc qui a été menée par
la Maison de l'Europe merci d'être venue
donc nous en parler sur ce plateau on va
rester dans ce cadre européen on va
partir cette fois-ci pour le Parlement
puisqu'il y a une opération qui a été
menée avec différents établissements
scolaires avec différentes délégations
et des différents pays membres
l'opération s'appelle euroscola toutes
les précisions vous sont apportées par
Anthony Rech qui a fait le déplacement
avec un établissement de Trappes
c'est en musique qui a commencé cette
journée heureuse là ou plus de 500
lycéens venus de 20 pays d'Europe ont
découvert le Parlement européen vendredi
dernier au programme comprendre les
enjeux de l'Union européenne en se
glissant dans le rôle d'un député mais
auparavant chaque porte-parole
présentait son école face à l'hémicycle
c'est super grand
puis non franchement déjà on est rentré
dans l'entrée je pensais qu'on était
déjà rentré sauf qu'en fait c'est pas du
tout rentré encore et c'était immense je
levais la tête je voyais pas je voyais
pas le toi c'était
21 élèves du lycée yvelinois issu de
filières CAP ou Bac Professionnel on
fait le voyage jusqu'en Alsace un
déplacement dont chacun veut garder un
souvenir mais avec tout de même beaucoup
d'enjeux est-ce qu'il faut comprendre
c'est que son jeûne et comme on a dit
agir c'est la jeunesse qui va le faire
c'est la jeunesse qu'elle la relève et
je pense que c'est important que les
jeunes soient là présents ici et montre
leur implication l'effet le plus
important je pense sera en langue il
faudra qu'ils se rendent compte que
l'anglais est important et combien
important pour pouvoir échanger avec
ses élèves de différents pays une fois
les présentations terminées rien de tel
qu'un débat avec un député européen pour
s'adapter à cet univers institutionnel
suivi d'une initiation au système de
vote électronique après la pause
déjeuner les lycéens se sont répartis en
six groupes de travail autour de thèmes
comme l'avenir de l'Europe ou les
migrations avant d'en débattre dans
l'hémicycle mais au milieu de leurs
collègues espagnols ou lettoniens la
prise de parole dans une langue
étrangère s'avère parfois difficile
utile pour les élèves trappistes on se
rend compte que la France a 15 ans de
retard entre sur l'éducation de
l'anglais entre les autres pays de
l'Europe ça n'a rien à voir
c'était vraiment formidable il y avait
tellement de sièges on était 700
personnes cette journée c'est
logiquement ponctuée par l'hymne à la
joie au cours duquel les jeunes lycéens
ont porté fièrement les drapeaux
européens
retour donc ici à Guyancourt si vous
nous suivez en direct il est presque 19h
cette édition du 7 8 et maintenant
terminé la Maison de l'Europe de
Yvelines nous accompagné pour la cette
dernière partie d'édition Patrick Bonin
merci donc vice-président de la Maison
de l'Europe des Yvelines et Christine
Colleville coordinatrice administrative
du site c'est la fin de cette édition je
vous le disais je vous retrouverai lundi
avec de nouveaux invités dès 18h en
direct l'édition du week-end vous sera
présentée dès demain par Catherine
zulato excellente soirée